we rarely see presidents act this  decisively  in getting us out of a commitment around  the world when presidents act decisively  it's usually to start an incursion and  it's considered patriotic by the right  when george w bush said on my order we  have started uh attacks in iraq after 9  11 and all of this wow decisive and  powerful well hold on a second is it  decisive and powerful to start an  incursion without actually thinking  through the consequences the way george  w bush did  this is the opposite but it is decisive  joe biden has drawn a line and is  getting us out of what george w w bush  started what barack obama didn't end  what donald trump didn't end biden is  ending it in the first year of his  presidency and that's good  and the situation has become very  chaotic and now joe biden has to figure  out what to do